I want you to stop the video
and first consider how much 27 is minus 1,
then how much is 27 minus 10.
Maybe it's too easy for you,
but let's look at it from a point of view
in the order of digits.
Take 27, at 27
we have 2 in the order of the decimal, which means 2 tenths.
And we see them here, two groups of 10.
And then we have 7 in the order of units
and we see these 7 units here.
I will now draw one,
I take out one, or else one unit,
because here is the order of units,
so I will scratch one.
I scratch one this way.
And how much remains after?
I still have two tens,
so I will write 2 in the order of the decimal,
I still have 2 in the order of the decimal.
How many units do I have now?
There were 7 units, I scratched one
and now there are 6 units,
so 2 decades and 6 units, that's 26.
Now let's think about 27 minus 10.
Again, this is 27 (2 tens and 7 units)
and now we will not bring forth units,
but we will draw 1 tenth.
Just remember that 10 is actually a dozen.
It sounds like I repeat the same thing,
over and over,
but I really want you to grasp the meaning of the place.
This is the order of the decimal and we have a number 1 there,
so I'll get 1 decimal and 0 units.
Let me scratch a tenth.
To scratch a tenth, maybe I'll scratch this one.
I will do it with a color that looks better.
Here, I scratched her. How old are you?
How many dozens?
Now I have only one complete group of 10,
i. I have one tenth, she is here in the order of the dozen.
How many units do I have?
I still have 7 units,
so I still have 7 in the order of units.
Therefore, 27 minus 10 is 1 tenth and 7 units, or 17.
Here is another possible way of thinking,
maybe it's your decision
from the beginning of the video.
If we subtract a unit,
we decrease the order of units by 1,
therefore we get 26 from 27.
But if we get 10,
then we reduce the order of the decimal places by 1,
therefore instead of 2 we will have 1
in the order of the tenths.
From 27 we get 17.
Here the order of the units does not change.